bismillah hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the Deen show I may be your
host and today we're gonna get some good
advice you're a Muslim you should be
happy you've chosen to consciously
submit your entire self not to a man not
to anything in creation but the creator
of the heavens and earth the one God the
same God that Jesus peace be upon him
worship the same God that Abraham
worship the same God that the last and
final messenger called the people to
worship Allah that's the creator of the
heavens and earth there's no God besides
him and you're a Muslim you should be
happy and now some people are sad so we
want to give some some great advice so
people can get to be an optimistic of
the beautiful rewards of Jenna paradise
that are waiting for those who have
submitted themselves and stay on this
way all the way until death we're going
to be right back with shape liebe Sunni
to give us some advice on being happy
being happy right back on the DL
this is the
back here on addy show with dr. shake
will leave a suni how are you sure very
good from the lot excellent so I got a
chance to some of the other shows people
know that you're the vice president of
Al Maghrib Institute and also you're the
Imam of the Islamic Center the center of
Clearlake yes yes so now you're somebody
who's qualified to talk about a lot of
these issues that we talked about
serious issues you know and one of them
is because you know let's face it you
know sometimes I'm very excited to do
this show I'm very excited to sit with
people like yourself it gets me going it
gets me excited and you know and it's an
imam moussa is such a blessing but
there's also days in my life that you
know you get sad we're human beings so
we want to you know get some advice and
there's some other people out there who
you know they accept this beautiful way
of life and you know they feel like
maybe smiling a lot is not good you know
it's not good for the soul maybe they
turn from being a happy optimistic
person person being someone who's rigid
and and negative so you know we want
some encouragement and we want to know
what does Islam teach does it teach us
to be sad or to be happy okay first of
all I'm happy to be here come to LA and
I ask a Lost Planet Allah to give you
success in your show and to always make
you and your family and your viewer
happy all the time I mean let me start
by saying this this religion came to
stablish certain goal we call them
ultimate goal of Sharia of the Sharia
law one of this ultimate goal this year
I want established in Earth is to make
people happy so that's one of the
purpose of revealing this book of
sending the messengers of Allah so Allah
and basically all this teaching one of
the goal is to make people happy not
only in this worldly life and also in
the hereafter as well so happiness is
one of the goals of Islam one of the
goals of us now and it encouraged us to
be happy and teach us how to be happy
how to
overcome these challenges in life these
challenges in life a las panatela told
us that when he created us he is erotic
masha'allah quebec allah have put you
together thus color interpreted this
word put you together he said because
you are certain parts of your body been
put together and also certain emotions
been put together sometimes you're high
sometimes low sometimes you are happy
sometimes you make it sad sometimes
nervous suddenly calm and all these been
put together so all this psychological
issues that we go through and physical
issue that we we also notice in our body
the changes all been put together and to
make that sophisticated creation which
is human being so allah knows us more
than anybody else he's the one who
created us who has put us together made
us and also he told her that this life
will contain a lot of different
situations different challenges that
meet us and he told us how to deal with
it but the point is that if you follow
what he teach if you follow the
guidelines that he gave you he guarantee
you happiness guarantee
for this worldly life and the not just
the hereafter but this life life allah
Spinetta allah said those who believe in
me and will offer good deeds felony and
no higher on play and he said like this
any male or female usually he said
anyone but he emphasized on all of
humanity's regardless of their gender
male or female that they will believe
they have faith on me and they will
offer good deeds felony and no hat on
piyah so he who said I will let them
live good life happy life in this
worldly life then I would reward them in
the hereafter with the greatest reward
which is paradise so this verse telling
us the story work won this world alive
by living a very good happy life and
also in the Hereafter by entering
paradise so the reward of the good deeds
of your submission to your Lord we
find it here the tranquility the
serenity the happiness that the trust
that you have in your heart it will not
bring anything less than happiness to
your life now someone says you know what
look look look you know and they quote
this hadith and they say the Prophet SAW
solemn said that this life for the
believer is like a prison
and in this believers like agenda so he
goes he started had that prison
mentalities rigid and ruffed and their
happiness is far from his mind is this
how we should interpret this that we got
to be like you know unhappy first of all
this hadith means it doesn't mean that
this dunya is like a prison it means
that in this dunya that a certain thing
you are prevented from doing it like
when somebody imprison he doesn't have
access to everything that he is aware of
so in this dunya there are certain
things I don't have no access to it like
taking your money I cannot take it I
have no access to it i've been
preventing from doing this stealing from
you cheating you i'm been preventing as
muslim from having an intercourse with
his any woman it has to be my wife you
see so that's what means present it
means you've been prevented from certain
things like the prisoner are prevented
from certain things while the kafir has
no rules some of the people who don't
follow rules he make his own rules he's
not a prison it's another prison he can
do whatever he wants he can break any
law that he wants is that what this
habit means it never give that dark
image or look of this worldly life this
world lives beautiful the Prophet SAW
solemn said he pray and he supplicated
every day to his lord by saying oh allah
bless my ear bless my eyes bless my
strength so I can enjoy this life so I
can enjoy this life so this is part of
what we do as Muslim we really enjoy and
maximize our benefit from this life from
this life tell us for somebody just is
just coming over and there we know it's
a fact that Islam is the fastest growing
way of life in the world
today you know even more women are
coming than men you know correct me if
I'm wrong this is what we're seeing from
the statistics so many people are coming
from living life according to just
fulfilling their desires just anything
is like open to them now they come into
Islam and naturally Islam has some
restrictions okay if you want to be with
a woman or one more want to be with the
man you got to be married and you can't
drink alcohol and so many other things
that are harmful for you Islam cut it
off there's so much wisdom behind it but
some people because they're so used to
just doing things their own way
fulfilling their desires but now it's
LOM says hold on you got to stop here
some people might they I see they fall
into this depression for a little bit
how do they break out of this so they
can really be happy first of all it's a
statistic you're speaking very
interesting to know that there is woman
are more likely to be unhappy than men
you go through a depression than men
more women than men yeah there's one
more unhappy than men yeah and it's
interesting since you're talking to a
modern woman coming to Islam because I
believe Islam it provide happiness
tranquility serenity security but why
people feel happy when the interest nah
I don't feel I don't believe that
fulfilling earlier desires gonna make
you happy
actually what's so beautiful about this
religion it's free you from being slave
to anything but Allah what is created
but you're created you not slave to your
desire you're not enslaved by the
Shabbat you're not slave of yourself you
not slave the money that you go or after
that's why the Prophet assalam said
Terry sir Abdul Dena - Abdul Hameed so
he said so Allah the one who take the
money as his God he will live in misery
he will never be happy
and the one who will take business as
his God he will never be happy why
because the moment you worship the money
you worship the one who owns the money
who controlled the money and and so
forth but when the moment you submit
yourself to Allah you only slaved him
you only controlled by him nobody else
control your life except him and that
the ultimate freedom actually
that's the ultimate treat and that's one
of the reason you feel happy you know
I'm not entitled to anyone in the world
except my Creator except the Creator
let's take a break and we right back
with more here an additional death and
the day of judgment the mercy of Allah
these are the things that finally made
me realize there is no time to delay
anymore I want you to take my Shahada
right there the essence of spirituality
is to become more sincere to Allah spend
whatever but to play death itself it is
very very scary but it brings you back
to reality there is a life which is
everlasting and you have to make a
conscious decision of which a group of
people do you want to be people I'm
having over the people of hell
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about being happy how we can get
from being depressed and sad to
something Islam encourages want to be
happy so these are would you say people
confuse the two with fun somewhat you
might receive as fun you know go and
drink in and club in and all these
things which I actually then have some
really negative side effects and that
leads to depression where Islam
prohibits these things because this is
for the betterment of society and and
and not confusing the two where true
happiness comes from what you said being
a slave not to these things but slave to
the one who created everything you know
there's about sixteen thousand people or
ask those questions so identify
happiness yeah and people identify
happiness by saying it is buy happiness
in wealth and been married health good
health basically having a lot of money
traveling and things like this I mean I
believe all having fun you know whatever
it is I think these tools to happiness
hmm this is not happens happiness is not
in money there's a lot of people have
money they're not happy a lot of people
drink you're not happy actually drink
because they're not happy and after
drinking they will be more sad more
depressed they're after using drugs
people go extremely low even for a
moment they drug themselves they deceive
themselves that's not happiness
happiness it is when you are content in
win inner soul your self from inside
content and your soul is basically and
rest in peace and tranquility when there
is serenity inside your your heart and
this is you will not find it until you
find until your soul find its way to God
find its right to the creator of this
soul basically it's one of the things
that the slant teaches about happiness
which is I thought it is very unique
Islam always asked us to be positive in
the way we think we have a positive
mental attitude towards everything will
always looks positive to the future will
look positive to our Lord anything
decreed upon us anything he legislate
for us we look at it as a positively the
Prophet SAW
son L was the most positive person Kenny
or Jim in fact he was an optimistic so
silent and loved optimism which is one
of the things it makes you really happy
that you always be positive about
basically everything around you
everything happening to you don't look
at it in a negative way it's the end of
of the word or you know what that's a
that that's it no you always see
opportunities in your difficulties and
that would set you apart from pessimist
people who always see difficulties and
their opportunities so if you look for
example the prophet sallallaahu re wa
salem told us to build that optimism in
us he said whenever you pray to Lord you
always ask for the highest things you
don't even ask for the low thing you ask
for the highest level of paradise when
you ask a lot anything in life you
always know that he will answer to you
sometimes by giving it to you sometimes
by giving breaks giving you breaks in
life things that might harm you in
future and a los matadore evented from
having giving you a lot of breaks in
your life and sometimes you keep it as a
form of free work for you in the
hereafter so I ain't know for sure that
whatever I pray for is something been
answered also you see the Prophet SAW
solemn said when you pray to him don't
say Oh forgive me if you wish no say
forgive me when you pray your heart full
of trust that there is out there a god
and the Lord he listening and he will
give me basically that what I want you
live if you want to be happy you always
see the light in front of you there is
experiment done in the lab and two rats
one of them was in a basically container
full of water and it's dark in 30
minutes this rat sinked died Wow okay
they put the same exact rod similar to
it in the same exact environment the
only difference there were lights on one
of the side of this container you know
that right
continuous swimming for how long 36
hours 36 hours
so in verses thirty minutes that he sink
in 30 minutes because there is no hope
no light he give up that one basically
700 times more than the previous one 36
hours swimming why because he see the
light and this is human being when you
see the light when you see a lost planet
arada even if you don't even physically
but you seem through his message through
his what he given to it he gave to us
you see the the path that he had chosen
for us you will have that strength to
continue to keep going not to give up
now it's not about the time to give it's
about to push it's about to go farther
it's about to not even to survive it
puts you in a mood of strife to strive
for the best and to aim for the best for
yourself and that's what's really make
you happy now someone says look look
shake you know that it sounds good it's
all sounds good but you know what you
know I just lost my son I have you know
my mother and my father who's got cancer
and I got to deal with this every day
you know that fierceness sounds like
giving up oh it's not happening to you
why is it happening to me and they
really get into pressed they say you're
not in my shoes until you walk in my
shoes then talk what would you say to
this person I'll tell you I know that
you are there's so many people out there
they have a lot of problems in life I
know that but as I know there's so many
problems out there I know also there are
so many solutions out there the Prophet
SAW solemn said Allah never sent in this
earth that disease unless there is a
cure for it some people will find it to
son before wouldn't so what I'm saying
he had no pain which the great Muslim
scholar said that these diseases are not
the physical is only even psychological
diseases economical problems there are
solutions for it it's your role to
search for it it's rule you wrote to
figure out the wisdom behind it you know
yes the prophets of Solomon and his time
a man came he used to come to them as a
new Muslim and the Prophet missed him
then he's worse son so he said he's
depressed at home his son passed away
was in stats of depression he is home he
didn't come to the Muslim emo the
Prophet went and visited him and
celina sides authentically the Prophet
told this man if you wish I'll pray to
my Lord and Allah will resurrect the son
to you right now and you enjoy his
company until you die or you will be
patient and this son will be waiting for
you in the day of judgement we'll take
your hand to enter from any gate of the
parody of the it's the eight gates of
paradise that you wish from any gates
you can enter he will lead you into it
yes it seems to be very sad that he died
but you know what what is waiting for
him in the hereafter is way greater than
just having this boy or this having this
sometimes yes you didn't get that phone
call for the job that you will praying
for it maybe you didn't get that woman
that you were or that man that he prayed
for so many times to have her or him as
your spouse maybe you never got that
opportunity that you've been seeking but
you know what allah subhanaw taala did
not give it to you for any reason but
because he know that's not the best for
you
you sometimes we want to God to act
about according to our timeline but he
act according to his timeline and
according to his wisdom yes according to
what he sees the best for us and that
what Islam make us see Allah in this way
in this positive attitude and that will
keep us going and going and going and I
know for sure that in the end of the
days that it will be the best for me
tell us and again I I got this from
listening to one of your lectures and
you had talked about a brother that you
knew who something happened to him and
he was stuck in a hospital he was always
so busy but then at this moment are you
recalling the story yes that he sat in
the hospital and at that time he made
the best out of his time and he
memorized the Quran can you share their
story with us
yes so many times so many times that the
difficult moment that it goes in our
life it can turn to be the best things
ever happen to our life I ain't no
brother who had the influence of the
virus but his strike his spine basically
and he was literally came move and this
one of the people who who always you'll
see him everywhere
he
pick somebody from the airport he tried
to help this family he always watch a
lot in the moon in any inaction so to
see that person's paralyzed is very hard
and one of my family went to visit him
and he said at the moment I walk into
the house into his basically room in the
hospital with a big smile in his face he
said you know what hamdullah now I have
time to set and to be able to be able to
memorize the Quran I'll be able to
Martha and he was able to do that in two
or three years I think down on the road
he was able to walk and Hum Dil us
through physical therapy he was able to
walk you know limping a little bit
but he regain his strength yes at that
moment you think it's the worst thing
happened to you but you don't know a
lost part I'll let you go through hard
time because he want to prepare you you
know what's the difference between the
Black Diamond and charcoal what session
it's they are all from the same organ
the only different that the Black
Diamond the most expensive rock in the
face of the earth versus that cheap
charcoal yeah that this one has the
ability to peer pressure and this one
doesn't
they also have the ability to pair the
pressure go through this difficult time
with patient with suburb they will come
out of it like this diamond very
valuable and the loss my daughter's eyes
there are 30 truth when it wears amazing
amazing we'll be back with more here on
the detail sit tight when outside
everything looks good you see the
hundred thousand dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is a life this is this is like no
paradise right here
with my hands up to go into someone's
heart to change the heartbeat your job
is to tell people what the truth is and
the aliaga days while we're sitting here
I'm sitting here constantly paying for
the disease
back here on the Dean show with doctor
liebherr Sunni and no matter what
happens you don't ever want to give up
absolutely whenever you feel it's the
time to throw a towel you know that's
the time to keep on the ring and you the
time to keep going and to push for
farther this is the time you stay it's
the time you dig you're here and not the
time to quit so what can a person do
when you feel like it's just getting
overbearing overwhelming and you feel
like a test is put put on you that you
know like a lost hunt Allah the God
Almighty the creator is saying like you
feel like that that that first where he
says you know they were tested so hard
they felt like when is the help of Allah
gonna come when you're feeling like that
what do you do the moment you see that
the moment you remember that Allah
cement Allah is watching me seeing me
hearing me and a lot of planning for me
the best and I start acting upon what I
know is the right thing you know I have
we have to learn how to move on in our
life don't ever stuck in in a situation
or in a time of difficulty and you think
that's the end of it no go ahead and
explore other areas in life maybe did it
work out in this area maybe you need
it's a time to discover something else
maybe it's the time to move on to move a
new place a new job a new person a new
environment just move on in your life
with trust in Allah Spano Dodd you know
smile at the at basically the word or
will smile back to you you know but
instead of talking about if it's not
talking about your problem all the time
talk at your problem try to solve it
find new solutions maybe Allah want to
direct you to find a new solutions to
the problem that you are going through
or the difficulty that you are have you
have right now
so you see you mentioned smiling so this
is something where some people they you
know feel like okay I'm religion I gotta
be rigid and no smile you're saying
smile yes the Prophet SAW said let one
of his several of his companions they
said every time we meet the Prophet
Allah and we see him he smile has big
beautiful smile in his face this is the
the prophets of Solomon how he always
looked like he used to smile more than
anybody else he's to joke with his camp
and smile very happy person very
friendly person so the law diario solemn
and fortunate as he said some people for
some reason they're not very smiley
faces I always tell the people some
people maybe feel they'd lost their
smile I have a good news for you
you're smart didn't good didn't go
anywhere it's right under your nose it's
right under you know just smile and and
see how this's will change you the
Prophet SAW solemn said smile is a form
of a charity a form of charity it's make
you could add you every time you smile
to someone it doesn't matter what that
person's ethnicity is he's related to me
or not this religion I just smiling is a
beautiful thing and it's not gonna make
other people's happy only it's gonna
make you also happy couple more points
just tell us this I feel is very
important shake you know dwelling too
much into the past I should've did this
I could've did that or worrying so much
about the future you know oh if this
happens to me if I don't do it you know
just dwelling too much in the past going
too much and worrying yourself about the
future this contribute to you being
miserable should you avoid these things
how I balance this out absolutely let me
tell you worrying worrying a lot or so
much about the future it will never
empty the future from its worry or its
sorrow
it will only empty your today from its
strength that's only what gonna happen
to you you know what as a Muslim
our main focus on now what I can do
today it's not about the past if I did
something in the past I learned from it
and the future it's in the hand of Allah
you know what it is now today what I can
do now to make myself a B what I can do
to make the people around me happy
what can I do to make the environment
and the people and the community that I
love again better place for me and for
them and for our children it's about now
what you should do as for worrying about
the future you know what you don't know
how long you're gonna live you just
enjoy your your life to die by asking
allah subhanaw taala to bless you and to
help you to worship Him to be closer to
him and to basically fulfill your day
where
what will make you happy and your family
as well
and that seems like busy doing good
because idle time it seems like if you
if you're getting bored you're gonna
find it's gonna leave room for Shaitaan
to to get into your head so these things
that you mentioned is is keeping
yourself doing good things keeping
yourself doing contribute to
contributing to society you know a Lost
Planet Allah give us a lot of gifts yeah
and these talents that we have it's a
loss gifts to us but what we do with it
it's our gifts back to Allah yeah so it
is really about how you're gonna use all
these gifts that are like giving it to
you and and that's why you have to keep
yourself busy doing and using these
things that the law of giving you and in
the right way thank you once again for
being with us may God Almighty Allah
reward thank you thank you
and some more great advice the opposite
of sad is to be happy and you gave you
some great great advice on how to be
happy because this is what Islam
encourages us don't be sad be happy and
continue to come back here to the Deen
show each and every week we got a new
show for you and we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be unto you